امام القضاء وتحت قوس المحكمه نسف محامي
له مسك مزاعمه السابقه بانه كان قد توصل
الى اتفاق مسبق مع صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه السعوديه قبل ان ينشر تغريده
الشهيره التي اعلن فيها انه يدرس سحب اسهم
تسلا من بورصه نيويورك وتحويلها الى شركه
خاصه وانه امن تمويلا لذلك
التغريده التي نشرها ماسك في سبعه اغسطس
2018 تسببت بارتفاع حاد لسهم قبل ان يعود
للتراجع بحده اكبر عندما تبين عدم صحه
وجود التمويل لواجهه ماسك بعد ذلك دعوه
قضائيه من عدد من المساهمين في الشركه
الذين اتهموه بتظليمهم والتسبب بغسائر
كبيره لهم في ذلك الوقت اكد ماسك انه لم
يكن يكذب زعيما ان الصندوق الاستثمارات
السعوديه
لكن محامي الدفاع عن ماسك الاكسبير تخلى
عن هذه المزاعم تماما في مرافعته
الافتتاحيه امام المحكمه الفيدراليه في
سان فرانسيسكو ولجا الى تمريرات اخرى
للتغريده بعيده عن السعوديه
فقال ان مصر مع مايكل ديل رئيس شركه دل
ومستثمرين في جولنا ساكس وسيفروليتمان
لاقناعهم بتمويل الخطه المحامي اقر بتسرع
ماسك في نشر التدريب قائلا انه اتخذ قرار
نشرها في جزء من الثاني بعد ان قرا مقالا
اخباريا تتضمن معلومات عن استثمار
السعوديه بقوه
اقر امام القضاه بان الصندوق السعودي لم
يسمع كلمه واحده عن مصر لتحويل الى شركه
خاصه
يحاول المحامي اخذ القضيه باتجاه اثبات
حسن النيه بقوله ان عدم الدقه او الضبابيه
في تغريدات المسك لم تؤثر على الاسواق اذ
انه كان يعمل بالفعل على تحويل الشركه الى
خاصه
محافظ صندوق الاستثمارات العامه ياسر
الرميات كان قد رفض الادلاء بشهادته امام
المحكمه بناء على مذكرات استدعائهم من قبل
هذه المذكرات غير مكتمله وتفتقده للدواء
موقف مصر القضيه اصبح اكثر تعقيدا الان
اذن محامي للدعاء اكد للقضاه ان ماسك
النشابه من دون ان يكون لديه اتفاقا
لتمويل الصفقه ومن دون ان يعرض الامر على
مجلس النداء